>>> AN AUTISTIC TEEN FROM
CALIFORNIA WHO WENT MISSING
NEARLY THREE YEARS AGO HAS BEEN
FOUND IN UTAH.
DEPUTIES IN SUMMIT COUNTY
DISCOVERED A YOUNG MAN IN FRONT
OF A STORE WHO HAD BEEN
WANDERING THE AREA WITH A
SHOPPING CART FOR WEEKS.
THE TEEN EITHER REFUSED OR JUST
COULDN'T GIVE HIS NAME, BUT
OFFICERS EVENTUALLY FIGURED OUT
HIS IDENTITY BY SEARCHING
THROUGH A LIST OF MISSING
PEOPLE.
THE DISCOVERY LED TO AN
EMOTIONAL PHONE CALL WITH THE
TEEN'S FAMILY WHO HAD FEARED
THAT HE WAS DEAD.
CNN'S CAMILLA BERNAL JOINING US.
OH, MY GOSH.
WHAT A STORY.
TELL US MORE.
>> YEAH.
THIS IS REALLY A REMARKABLE
STORY.
SUMMIT COUNTY SHERIFF'S OFFICE
IN UTAH DESCRIBING IT AS SERVING
WITH COMPASSION.
THERE WERE A NUMBER OF CALLS
MADE TO REPORT CONNERJACK
OSWALD.
HE'S 19 YEARS OLD.
HE WAS NOT BREAKING ANY LAWS,
BUT OFFICERS WENT OUT THERE
ANYWAY AND THEY WERE CHECKING UP
ON HIM.
INITIALLY HE REFUSED ANY HELP
AND THEN LAST SATURDAY, THE
DEPUTIES WENT OUT THERE AGAIN
AND THIS TIME THEY WERE ABLE TO
HELP HIM.
ALL OF THIS WAS CAUGHT ON BODY
CAM VIDEO.
AND TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT
HAPPENED.
>> YOU LOOK LIKE YOU'RE
SHIVERING.
YOU COLD?
YOU WANT TO COME SIT IN HIS CAR
AND WARM UP FOR A MINUTE?
WE CAN'T HAVE YOU SITTING IN
FRONT OF THE DOOR HERE ALL
NIGHT.
>> SORRY, I CAN'T HEAR YOU.
>> AS LONG AS I'M NOT BEING
TAKEN ANYWHERE.
>> YOU'RE NOT BEING TAKEN
ANYWHERE.
JUST COME IN THE CAR AND WARM
UP.
>> WHERE IS YOUR SHOPPING CART
AT?
>> IT GOT STOLEN.
>> IT GOT STOLEN?
THAT'S NO GOOD.
>> [ INAUDIBLE ].
>> OKAY.
>> GO AHEAD AND SIT IN MY FRONT
PASSENGER SEAT WHERE IT'S WARM.
>> COME IN HERE AND WARM UP.
>> YOU HAVE A KNIFE OR GUN OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT?
>> NO BAZOOKA, CROSSBOW.
>> OKAY.
JUST HAVE A SEAT.
WARM UP.
WHERE WERE YOU AT WHEN YOUR
SHOPPING CART GOT STOLEN?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> WHAT'S THAT?
DOESN'T MATTER.
>> NOW AFTER THIS ENCOUNTER, IT
WAS A DISPATCHER WHO WENT
THROUGH PAGES AND PAGES OF
MISSING CHILDREN AND THAT PERSON
WAS ABLE TO FIND CONNERJACK
OSWALD.
THEY WENT BACK TO THE REPORT AND
REALIZED THAT HE'D BEEN MISSING
SINCE SEPTEMBER OF 2019 FROM
CLEARLAKE, CALIFORNIA.
THEY WERE ABLE TO GET A HOLD OF
HIS MOM.
AND SHE TOLD OFFICERS THAT HE
HAD A VERY DISTINCTIVE BIRTHMARK
ON HIS NECK.
THE DEPUTIES FOUND THAT
BIRTHMARK AND THEN HIS STEPDAD
WENT TO UTAH TO IDENTIFY HIM IN
PERSON.
THAT MOMENT WAS ALSO CAUGHT ON
POLICE BODY CAM.
IT WAS A REALLY MOVING MOMENT
WHEN THE STEPDAD CALLED THE MOM
TO LET HIM KNOW THAT HE WAS
INDEED ALIVE.
TAKE A LISTEN TO THAT MOMENT.
>> THE MISSING PERSON PHOTO THAT
WE LOCATED WAS THIS.
>> YEAH, THAT'S --
>> AND THEN THE PHOTO THAT CAME
FROM NEVADA BEFORE THE ARREST
WAS THIS.
>> HOLY CRAP.
>> IS IT HIM?
>> A LITTLE BIT OLDER, BUT,
YEAH.
>> AND WHAT STOOD OUT TO ME WAS
THE EARS.
YOU KNOW, NOT KNOWING HIM.
>> YEAH.
>> HE LOOKS PRETTY SIMILAR TO
THIS.
HIS HAIR IS LONGER RIGHT NOW.
HIS BEARD IS A LITTLE THICKER.
>> YEAH.
>> MY SWEETHEART IS ALIVE.
OH, MY GOD
.
>> YEAH, I DEFINITELY WILL DO MY
BEST TO BRING HIM HOME.
>> AND THE SHERIFF SAID THERE
WAS NOT A DRY EYE IN THAT ROOM.
WE KNOW THAT HE IS RECEIVING
CARE AND RESOURCES AND IS
EXPECTED TO REUNITE WITH H